[Musique]
l'action apple
venez les enfants je vais vous montrer
quelque chose ça c'est une centrale
hydroélectrique l'eau qui s'écoule à
travers le barrage fait tourner les
turbines qui produisent de l'électricité
c'était plus huppés est ensuite conduite
par des fils électriques et ce jusqu'à
la maison où nous en profitons pour mais
l'électricité d'une invention moderne à
l'âge de pierre tout ça n'hésitez pas
vous pensez on venait juste de découvrir
le feu soit plus tard au temps de nos
ancêtres les gaulois
il y avait la langue kabyle un peu plus
tard encore dans les châteaux du moyen
âge on s'éclairait à la bougie
soit on se servait de la bougie dans les
campagnes
tous les nouveaux j'ai un message à oui
toi sois plus près de nous dans le
château du roi soleil il y avait un
valet spécialement chargé d'éteindre
toutes les chandelles allison quel
boulot soit fait pas chaud à le volet
fait un peu penser à cette époque les
grandes décisions se prenaient à la
lueur d'une lanterne
[Musique]
heureusement un bon jour et ce avant
inventa l'électricité l'eau et
l'électricité ça peut faire très mal
mais cette électricité c'est dangereux
et je vous défends de toucher en prie je
vais faire des cours soyez sage a dit de
ne pas toucher
t'inquiète pas je vais juste jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
[Musique]
ce demain préparent une grève litige
voyez pas
[Musique]
couper tout occupé à langon ça ne
marchait plus
remettez courant maintenant écoutez moi
on ne touche pas aux prises électriques
pas besoin d'être une lumière pour
comprendre ça renvoie tout va tout
[Musique]
et merci
il